all right here's the story From
timcast.com Russia deploys sub-armed
with weapon of the Apocalypse the
Poseidon torpedo could destroy European
cities by creating a tsunami wave the
size of four and a half football fields
well the sub named belgarad is that you
pronounce it has disappeared from its
harbor in the Arctic promoting NATO to
warn member countries that Russia may be
planning to test its Poseidon torpedo
which is an InterContinental
nuclear-armed nuclear-powered autonomous
weapon I think that should be prompting
NATO to warn from two countries yeah
yeah oh yeah I see there's a p it's
supposed to be prompting so uh some
people have said it's 100 Megaton
torpedo the more reasonable estimates is
two megatons which is still nightmarish
apparently this this autonomous drone
torpedo has his nuclear Powers got its
own small reactor which means it has an
infinite range not literally infinite
but that it could hit anything on the
planet it could go and just hit it
so he's deployed this uh this sub
they're saying he's going to test it and
they're not convinced that the weapon
will is actually can be used just now
somebody's that's not coming from me
that's not me either sound no nothing's
popping up
someone keeps making it comes from the
Mainframe no it's coming from the
command computer we don't have speakers
on the computer somewhere maybe it says
Bluetooth never heard that noise before
it's coming from it's coming from Luke's
face
all right so anyway
that's right it could be here it could
be the subject maybe so this uh this
theoretically could hit uh anywhere on
the planet now I don't know if this is
the the the big concern because it's not
been tested and I guess the estimate
here is they say it's not gonna be
operational until 2027. I suppose if
they have it and it's like partially
functional why not test it if they need
to you know what I mean like well now's
not a good time to test a weapon because
it'll look like they're preparing to
launch I I think geopolitically the the
mediocre intelligent people will be like
oh no that means they're getting
prepared to use it well this is why
which I guess they technically are this
is why the U.S like canceled a few you
know was it like Titan missile tests but
what I mean is if they haven't tested it
yet why why does that matter if they
have have it and it might or might not
work they will use it if they need to
and we can flip a coin and wonder which
city is going to get wiped out in a
radioactive tsunami or we can just be
like hey maybe we should stop the war
also how many of these do they have how
many autonomous weapons are available
like this is the future of modern war at
least the present day modern Wars
autonomous nuclear weapons that can take
out cities from a distance well we need
to be you know honest with ourselves we
don't know exactly what they have a lot
of the times military technology is far
behind what the general public believes
is even out there but for for the record
Russia had
6255 nuclear warheads that's that's the
recorded uh amount that of course
everyone publicly talks about but again
what we're talking about here is is a
new form of Weaponry that is going to of
course launch a nuclear weapon
underwater and launch a tsunami with
with radioactive waste onto a shoreline
this is what they're talking about I
don't know how you test these certain
types of weapons but it's not just the
submarine that we should be worrying
about Israeli intelligence is also
documenting how Russian bombers capable
of a nuclear attack were just found near
Finland there's of course the nuclear
train that people are talking about so
it definitely does seem like Russia is
allowing a lot of its nuclear assets to
be deployed whether tested or or not we
don't know exactly what's going on here
but regardless I think this is news that
I think we should be paying more
attention to here's what people need to
understand too I'd be willing to bet
the first the first Target of any kind
of nuclear strike it's going to be
tactical nukes it's going to be nuclear
artillery so Russia will fire at a
military Target probably a shot across
the bow meaning it'll hit nothing and
then it'll be devastating and that's
them being like we're doing it then if
the war continues they'll use they'll
use uh nuclear artillery against
military targets then they'll probably
use lower yield nuclear weapons against
smaller cities it'll it'll draw up but
if it really gets to full-scale nuclear
war
then you don't need to worry about New
York dcla or Chicago you need to worry
about small towns
they're not going I would imagine Russia
is not going to Target if they're going
for a shock and awe kind of nuclear
strike against America U.S city which I
I don't think is very likely at all it's
going to be a small City what's a what's
what's a good example name a small City
can you think about Dubuque Dubuque love
you guys that's a good point it's a good
City actually Dubuque Iowa yeah yeah
that's that actually I don't their
population it's probably a couple
hundred thousand maybe but this is
exactly what I mean if the people who
live in small towns think ah it's New
York uh it's DC I got anything to worry
about
if they want to cause shock and all
damage and really paralyze the economy
and the American people
going after a big city just confirms
that they feel safe we're not in the big
city we don't got anything to worry
about it would be bad it would be scary
but you know we're in the middle of
nowhere they go after Dubuque everyone
everywhere in the country is going to be
worried that's what freaks me out like I
don't know if 911 I don't know who did
it I still don't but I am not putting it
past the government to Nuke one of its
small towns or cities and blame it on
the Russians like I that's been on my
mind lately it's like a full scale 200
000 people are just of evaporated or
illiterate and then then they're and
then everyone's in such pain and Trauma
that whoever they point you towards you
end up being like I'm I'm so angry okay
they're the enemy okay I need an enemy
right now and that's just you be on
guard for that kind of crap right so
it's like Chernobyl melts down and
they're picking that that radiation in
Switzerland yeah so that's a thousand
miles and so what you know if you even
if you nuke to Dubuque well what's
within a thousand miles of Dubuque and
you have you have so many cities Des
Moines Chicago like you have so many
cities that could also be affected by
the Dubuque it's all we're going to call
it it's all going to blow East
it's a very Russian way to say it they
like DB and all together you know yeah
so we have this other story Luke just
mentioned it the Russian nuclear
military train is seen on the move and
possible warning to the West that Putin
is prepared to escalate his Ukraine war
the military hardware belongs to 12th
main directorate of the Russian mod
specialist division is dedicated to
storage maintenance and and provision of
nukes here I was saying this earlier
everybody right now is talking about
nuclear weapons but yo these things are
like what 80 years old not like every
nuke is 80 years old but the technology
you have to imagine they've developed
different weapons by now right yeah
absolutely without a shadow of a doubt I
mean buying weapons 80 years 80 years
what we've seen in Nagasaki and
Hiroshima and those attacked major
cities that were key infrastructure for
of course the the Japanese military they
had a lot of factories there they had a
lot of production there what's what's uh
Russia going to do bomb China for
producing all the infrastructure for the
United States it does it so so there's a
lot of complexities to our modern day
and there's also talk of low-yield
nuclear weapons that don't have any
radioactivity that just provide kind of
a big boom there uh what we're talking
about right now is just crazy crazy
stuff that that is even Preposterous
that we're at this level where we're
where we are at right now this is crazy
I want to go back to World War II and
just imagine what they were thinking
before the deployment of nuclear your
bombs right they had rocket at the V2
Rockets they had you know what they had
Zeppelins dropping stuff or something
well they were using B2 or B-52s to drop
I think it'd be 52. drop Fire Bomb a
firebomb Dresden before the nukes went
off so that right there was already kind
of like a dramatic escalation imagine if
they in World War II were concerned
about the most powerful and devastating
weapon of like 1860. you know like we're
talking about 80 years ago we developed
these these these fission bombs these
nuclear bombs and then of course since
then we've dramatically increased their
power by like 1 000 fold and put them on
icbms now we have this torpedo I'm
willing to bet I'm just gonna say it off
top of my head anti-matter weapons
probably exist in great yield you don't
know what's coming this is the this is
the point of modern Wars you don't know
a big point of it you watch the Great
War on YouTube fantastic Channel a
documents World War one week by week
they didn't know what machine guns were
not really they didn't know that they
were running into a machine gun for like
weeks and weeks and even maybe months
they just got up and just kept running
and just kept getting killed millions of
people who just keep running into this
new weapon that they didn't understand
and then in World War II they didn't
think a nuclear bomb was going to take
out Hiroshima they didn't know that that
existed that that potential was there
but
lo and behold one in a split second
things can change so this is a story
that broke last week last Friday the
first transgender uh officer in the US
Army right arrested being a Russian spy
traitor to our country now this is what
I found very very interesting in the
story what were the Russians after
so what what were presumably they
wanting what were they wanting what
information right that's right well they
weren't going after Delta Forces like
capacity of Firepower or what special
weapons they had or night vision goggles
they were going after the medical
records now what does this mean Gordon
Chang says that China is working on you
know biomedical
DNA attracted you know devastating I'm
not sure how you would even call it like
what would you even call it DNA markers
that say like we're going to make a
specific death for you based on your
genetic code and China's going full in
on this technology to figure out how to
kill full groups of people of course and
this of course is the James Bond so yeah
because you applied for the last James
Bond movie you don't want them to know
that you're attacking them that's the
point they want to do it invisibly
quietly subtly you don't want to drop
weapons that you see coming you guys
know about stuxnet
this was a cyber weapon developed by the
U.S and Israel to blow up Iranian
nuclear centrifuges to stop them from
obviously you know getting getting
nuclear power or weapons or whatever you
want to call it so this was a a cyber
weapon that was basically just spattered
across the planet they infected
everything and said sooner or later it
will find its way onto their computers
and it did
it did nothing until it found the
centrifuges and then it caused them to
spin until they exploded
but this virus was apparently on regular
machines and Industrial machines but it
wouldn't wouldn't do anything that's
exactly it I wonder if back then someone
saw that and said we can do that in the
computer can we do that in a person you
create a virus that will in BIO weapon
that will infect every person on the
planet but only cause damage in certain
DNA yeah was it what movie was it James
Bond James Bond this was the exact plot
of the last James Bond film and we know
that the Central Intelligence Agency has
a bureau in Hollywood that they openly
push the new Horrors to humanity through
Hollywood Cinema and that they are
probably concerned about this because
this is what was happening this exact
thing was happening James Bond film
there was a um there's a black character
female character right people thought
she might have been the new James Bond
right 007 takes time off she becomes
double level seven anyway at the end of
the film The Mad Scientist is like I
could make a disease they're in there
his lair and he goes I could wipe out
your entire race right that was that was
his threat to her is that I could wipe
out your entire People based on the
genetic code hold on hold on right who
would this most negatively impact not
the United States
but it doesn't have to be about your
ethnic genetics it could be about a
trigger so like an external stimuli a
light or a sound could trigger your
genetic to do the thing to activate it
could be
um something you eat it could be a feel
an emotion you have could trigger it
that's something some kind of chemical
release in your brain activates it or
something like that then they did a mass
murder of a group at the beginning of
the movie and I mean obviously it's not
a documentary okay like it's James Bond
film but they killed a specific targeted
group of people because they all took a
tablet right they took a pill that you
could give the military let's say uh
everyone in the military they all take
like very similar medicines obviously
vaccine mandates so on and so forth and
so you could Target them based on the
medicine that they take there was some
show that I was watching what was it
Fringe oh yeah French had an episode
like this right where this guy is
developing this kind of smell that if
you smell it it kills you did you you
guys he was trying to Target a specific
person through their genetic something
like that something like that I don't
know it's been yeah I haven't seen it in
a while yo this is crazy because it
feels like
we're all we all do these shows and
we're like nuclear weapons and then the
TV's like nuclear weapons and Putin and
everyone's like ah then meanwhile behind
the scenes and all the top secret you
know clearance stuff they're like if
only you knew dude bio weapons or no
joke well China was caught taking
people's coveted tests and then
genetically harvesting the DNA from it
U.S intelligence agencies were
specifically I was talking about this I
think a year ago on this show I was
saying hey the Chinese government is
stealing everyone's covet tests U.S
intelligence agencies are warning
medical facilities not to get uh rid of
their tests in a way where of course the
Chinese government could could get them
they have been getting them they have
been harvesting the data for multiple
reasons one is an economic reason
another reason could be of course a new
form of warfare germ warfare DNA
specific Warfare that I think is also on
the possibility but the more likely
possibility that of course people need
to understand here is that China also
wants to game the big Pharma market so
if they have everyone's DNA they know
what people would be getting sick of
they could start producing and
Manufacturing medicine to beat out big
Pharma and because come the next big
overruling kind of power so for all of
the people that may be listening and
they're going no that's crazy China's
not taking your DNA I Give You NPR China
wants your data and may already have it
February 24th 2021 from All Things
Considered they say as covet cases began
to rise a year ago a Chinese company
contacted several U.S states and offered
a set of testing Labs as a byproduct the
Chinese firm Beijing genomics Institute
would likely gain access to the DNA of
those tested
the offer was tempting for State
struggling at their own testing
facilities for a new virus and short
notice but U.S national security
officials urged the states to reject the
offer citing concerns about how China
might use personal data collected on
Americans we certainly reached out to
our partners in the community to make
sure blah blah blah blah this is just
one of the earlier stories yeah it
definitely makes you wonder why the
covet tests were free you know and
giving out to everyone no no hold on
though those who didn't return right so
what this is more about is facilities
where you'd pull up and they'd test you
and then we'll call you back later
exactly the covet tests you got at home
you like snorted into or whatever and
then you threw it you had to buy those
right right right but but the free ones
they they had your DNA sample no no the
ones they give you at your house they
were they were the same ones from the
grocery store or whatever yeah this is
what they're talking about is they were
there were places you could go to get
tested where you drive up in your car
they'd stick you in the nose and say
we'll call you back on Wednesday and let
you know that's where the concern is on
whether or not they were getting access
to your DNA I mean to Luke's Point how
much of our pharmaceutical is this
processed in China majority I mean the
vast majority I don't know the exact
number I'm sure it's easily fine you
know you usually find it and Google it
right now yeah vitamin C supplements all
of it antibiotics I just want to make
sure American Pharmaceuticals they go
into China I want to make sure I clarify
too as much as they go on to say that um
you know these states turned it down
this is funny they're like the National
Security said don't do it because you
know China would get access to your data
we certainly reached out to our partners
in the community to make sure oh it
sounds like it didn't happen NPR goes on
to say Beijing genomics Institute a
major Global player in the world of
genomics research reporters had a labs
and at least 18 other countries and
provided covet testing kits to 180
Nations including the US great U.S
officials stress their main concern was
preventing the establishment of
full-service Labs the officials do not
consider the testing kits to pose a
serious risk biotech companies in China
the US and elsewhere routinely collect
DNA and use it blah blah blah you get it
you get it so here's the other crazy
thing too is like ancestry and like was
it 2023 me I'm just looking it up people
are just like I'm gonna give my DNA and
then a company buys 23andMe who owns it
I don't know do you know the guy that
owns 23 and me personally I believe also
the FDA made an announcement that they
were taking some of the tests and
running uh uh larger uh projects and
scientific experiments with them based
off human DNA okay now I know it sounds
freaky right but hear me out what if the
genomics lab that is everybody's DNA
releases a virus and it turns people
into crazy like animal hybrids like
werewolves and lizard people wouldn't
that be cool uh um reality is a lot
scarier than your fiction here Tim
especially when you look at individuals
Animorphs animals
what animal well I'm not what animal
would you become if you were an animal
well I'm not saying that people get the
ability to choose a term saying like
they would be forcefully turned into a
variety of different animals like Lou
could be like a lemur guy and you know
it would be a horse dude or something
and can we start talking about the
billionaires thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there